ray Kinsler's paintings are like a who's
who of the American 20th century as a
young man his mentor was the famous
illustrator James Montgomery flank flags
best known work the drawing called Uncle
Sam was used for this World War 1 poster
but flags most treasured piece kinsler
told us was this nude of his model and
love Elsa Hoffman what do you remember
about that painting very sensual when he
painted people they breathed you could
feel the character in a way in there and
the whole personality after Flagg's
death in 1960 Kinzler helped clear out
Flags New York apartment I looked I
remember looking out of the window and
the pain he was there everything was in
place but the next time he visited the
beloved nude had vanished
Kinsler figured maybe a building workers
stolen I said it's probably the
superintendent poor aide or an elevator
operator who got his kicks out of
looking at a really hot nude and I
betcha it's in somebody's apartment in
Brooklyn that always intrigued me
because I wondered for many years had it
mysteriously disappeared or had been
stolen or was it just completely lost a
time collector and attorney James head
writes about what he calls the American
illustrators of beauty
two years ago he saw this picture in an
auction house catalog sure enough it was
the missing nude so you did instantly
recognize this picture absolutely so
what did you think
wife I would never see it this isn't
mysteriously disappearing nude and there
it was both head and Kinsler alerted
Heritage Auctions they might be selling
a stolen item and someone else noticed
too we received a call from James
Montgomery flakes granddaughter sergeant
mark Amundsen is with the New York City
Police Department she said that there
was an auction going on her
grandfather's stolen paint and was on it
sergeant
Amundsen usually investigates more
recent crimes where evidence is fresh
but in a case going back 58 years he
wasn't even sure he'd be able to find a
police report the big question was is
a report made in other words did anybody
ever report it stolen
essentially the sergeant had to
determine where the report would have
been filed and then search for it how
many records did you wind up looking at
to find this report roughly about six
thousand six thousand yes
why were you willing to even go through
all that she was adamant that the
painting was stolen and it's part of her
family's history part of the New York
history and American history so to get
an opportunity to investigate something
like that comes by once-in-a-lifetime so
I figured I'd take a shot and six
thousand reports later it's not very big
you do not yeah Wow good eyes there it
was one oil painting misplaced in manner
unknown that single phrase gave flags
descendants the ability to get the
painting pulled from the auction and put
it back where it belonged
with a family member as to where it
disappeared to all those years even the
detective can't say we can't prove one
way or the other especially with such a
time lapse that there was ever any
criminal intent and so I couldn't prove
that someone tried to steal it or it did
steal it all I can prove is that somehow
it went missing and it ended up on this
auction house or it ended up in the
hands of someone else but the story of
the painting is one James Montgomery
flag would likely have appreciated he
had a great sense of the ridiculous and
that life was it was he had an ironical
side to him as he said in his will
ugliness is everywhere but he said I
still believe beauty exists for CBS this
morning Saturday Anna Werner New York